- So my first job,
I worked at a
horse racing track.
- Okay, that's good.
- I would seat all the
pilled up old ladies.
- Yeah, yeah, yup.
- And I babysat my
cousin one time.
- Oh, there you go.
- For a whole summer,
and the great trick was
I taught him to go to bed
at 3:00 a.m., so he'd
wake up at like 1:00 p.m.,
his mom would come
home at three,
only had to watch
him for two hours.
- Perfect.
- Come and watch American
Gladiator, jump--
- There you go scheming,
I mean ruined his cycle.
- I ruined his whole life.
I ruined his whole life.
- Yeah, 100%, literally.
But, that's a good way to
make money right there.
- Thanks brother.
(upbeat guitar rock)
- Welcome to Stupid Questions,
I am Chris Distefano,
AKA Viking Head,
and we are with
Casey James Salengo,
AKA Cutie With a Bootie,
and he has got an album out.
It's called Wild
Country Phoenix.
And you also have a
great podcast called
The Good, the Dad, and the Ugly.
There it is.
- Look at that hand,
that's a thick hand.
- I appreciate that,
that is a hand that
gets a lot of work.
- Woo hoo hoo.
- [Chris] Wow.
(upbeat guitar rock)
- What mythical creature
would you like to ride?
- Cerberus.
- What's a Cerberus?
- Three-headed dog.
- Yeah.
- Protector of the river Styx.
- Yeah!
- Ride him through Hades.
- [Chris] Yeah.
(makes horse clomping
noise with mouth)
Dude is scrapping.
- Dude, I wanna
ride (bleep) Dumbo.
- Is that mythical thing?
- It's a flying elephant.
- Sure.
- With ears.
- I know who Dumbo
is. (laughing)
- It's not just a neighborhood,
you hipster shits.
- Whoa!
(upbeat guitar rock)
- If you could change
your first name,
what would you change it to?
- When I was younger, I
moved to a new school,
and I told everyone Casey
was short for Casanova.
So, I changed it to Casanova.
- Wow!
- And everyone found
out so everyone
at school called me Nova.
It was the coolest
I've ever been.
- That's hilarious!
- And then one time
somebody called my house,
looking for me,
and my mom's like, I
just hear my mom go,
"What? Casa, no, what?"
And she goes,
"Casey, what the (bleep) are
"you telling people at school?"
(upbeat guitar rock)
If you were given a
nickname off a diner menu,
what would you be called?
What would be, it's gotta
be from a diner menu.
- Tuna melt.
- Yeah, baby.
- Wouldn't that be cool?
- Yeah, the tuna melt.
- It's tuna, like a tough fish.
- I feel like you'd
be the Monte Christo.
- Saucy, ooh, yeah!
Well--
- Reuben, you could
look like a Reuben.
- I didn't think
about it long enough.
- Is there, like do you
like tuna and cheese, or--
- I feel like a tuna is like
a scrappy fish, you know?
- It is a scrappy fish.
- I consider myself
pretty scrappy.
The cheese, the melted cheese
is a layer of elegance.
So I'm kinda like the scrappy
guy with a layer of elegance.
- Tuna is a scrappy fish
when you think about it.
- Yeah, man.
Nobody gives any respect.
Just like me, I
don't get respected,
but I'm hey, listen, I've
been here since day one
and I'm gonna be
here 'til the end.
And they gonna love me.
- And I stink.
- And I (bleep)
stink. (laughing)
(upbeat guitar rock)
- How did you learn the
truth about Santa Claus?
- So I walked downstairs
to get my stocking.
I'm coming down the stairs,
I look on the couch.
I see my uncle butt naked.
My uncle is around my house,
big alcoholic,
you know, fun guy.
- Duh!
- But was completely naked.
- Right.
- Next to the Christmas tree,
some half-wrapped presents.
Clearly something had gone awry.
I'm like, well, alright, uh.
So I go around the corner,
the stocking is not filled.
- Right.
I start wailing crying.
- Sure.
- My mom just says, "Go to bed!
"Go back to bed."
So I go back to bed.
Her boyfriend goes down,
wrangles my uncle Randy
in the other room, throws him
under the dining room table.
And then he starts
wrapping the gifts.
And I'm like alright,
well this seems
like Santa wasn't involved
in this particular magic.
- Right.
And so you just figure it out.
- So I figure it out, but I
see my uncle Randy's balls.
(upbeat guitar rock)
- Did you have a good
time on Stupid Questions?
- I had such a good time, man.
Thanks for asking me questions.
- Dude, of course, bro, come on.
- Had fun hanging with
you, you're a fun dude.
- You get a stupid gift.
So here's what we got you.
- Oh my god, a baby kitty!
- This is a blind
cat singing karaoke.
I just figured you're a guy.
You like cats.
- I love cats.
- You like karaoke.
- Baby.
You're the best.
- There it is.
- I didn't know you
knew so much about me.
This is my best friend.
- Absolutely, dude.
Cats and karaoke, you
talk about it a lot.
And there you go, there it is.
What's its name?
- Chordley.
This is Chordley the cat.
- Sit on my arm like this.
- [Chris] There it is.
- This is the best
day of my life, folks.
- [Chris] Yes.
- (kissing noise) I love---
- You know he can eat tuna.
- Ah, tuna melt, me and tuna--
- It's just you.
Don't let the cat eat you.
- Thanks, man.
Give us a hug.
Give him a kiss.
(kissing noise)
- God, dude, you
smell like tuna.
(laughing)